This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Squarespace.
What if there was no Big Bang and the Universe
has been around forever?
Huh?
Hello!
I’m Ian O’Neill, space producer for Discovery
News, and I’m having a pretty hard time
wrapping my finite brain around a new model
that suggests the Universe has no beginning,
no end, no Big Bang, no Big Crunch, no Dark
Matter, no Dark Energy and that the Cosmos
is swamped in some kind of weird quantum fluid.
Seems kind of messy.
This may look like some sort of new crackpot
theory, but researchers in Egypt and Canada
have used sound mathematics and physics to
potentially answer some of the toughest questions
in modern cosmology.
And this is really exciting as ideas like
these have a habit of turning science on its
head if proven to be correct.
A continuing puzzle surrounding the Big Bang
is that if you shrink the entire universe
down to a point -- known as a “singularity”
-- all known physics breaks down.
Physicists don’t like it when physics breaks
down, so the moment of the Big Bang, when
the universe was a singularity doesn’t make
any physical sense.
Another puzzle that continues to confound
physicists is that Einstein’s general relativity
doesn't play nice with quantum physics.
Gravity, quite simply, does not FIT with our
current quantum models of the universe -- and
that’s a huge problem!
The hunt for evidence of quantum gravity is
therefore one of the biggest quests going
on in physics RIGHT NOW.
So, in a new paper published in the journal
Physics Letters B, the researchers propose
a model for the Universe that solves the “Big
Bang singularity paradox” and ties together
gravity and quantum dynamics.
To cut a very long and complex story short,
they revisited equations proposed in the 1950s,
and melded them with our current understanding
of quantum dynamics and cosmology.
Although it’s not a complete theory of quantum
gravity, it works quite nicely.
In our classical understanding of the universe,
there MUST be a beginning -- the Big Bang
-- and there MIGHT be an end -- known as the
“Big Crunch.”
That’s a product of the equations.
By combining all the observational evidence
and formulating theories to help explain what
we are seeing, the classical equations spit
out a universe of a finite age -- a universe
that is nearly 14 billion years old
But by melding quantum corrections with a
different mathematical approach at describing
the universe, this new model produces a universe
that has an INFINITE age.
Once compared with our observations of the
cosmos, the theoretical predictions agree
with our measurements of the cosmological
constant and removes the requirement for introducing
huge unknowns like dark matter and dark energy
-- the two “invisible” quantities that
we are having a real hard time explaining.
But what does it mean physically?
Well, if gravitons exist (and that’s a BIG
if), the universe must be filled with a “graviton
fluid.”
Gravitons are hypothetical quantum particles
that mediate the force of gravity.
But the only problem is that we don’t know
if they exist yet.
Although exciting, I doubt the cosmology textbooks
will be re-written quite yet.
Big Bang theory is widely accepted as it is
supported by several lines of observational
evidence -- from the cosmic microwave background,
thought to be the Big Bang’s afterglow,
to the Universal expansion that suggests all
galaxies came from a common point.
However, holes in our understanding about
how gravity plays in the quantum world puts
a huge question mark over many cosmological
and quantum ideas and our current Big Bang
model could be horribly flawed.
Regardless of whether there was a Big Bang
or not, this is a wonderful example of how
science works -- new hypotheses are tested
to formulate theories and observational evidence
tests those theories, regardless of how established
the models of the universe are.
All we need to do now is detect gravitons
in the Large Hadron Collider… no pressure
physicists!
We'd like to thank Squarespace for their support
of DNews.
Squarespace is the easiest way to create a
beautiful website, blog, or online store for
you and your ideas.
Squarespace features an elegant interface,
beautiful templates, and incredible 24/7 customer
support.
Try Squarespace, at Squarespace.com/dnews,
and enter offer code “DNews” at checkout
to get 10% off.
Squarespace.
Build it Beautiful.
Do you think Big Bang theory will be overturned
by gravitons?
Let us know in the comments, and subscribe
for more DNews every day!